[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique à la
veille du déconfinement en france
l'exécutif assure que les stocks de
masques sont largement suffisants et que
la capacité en test et massive
il aura fallu plus de deux mois dans
l'urgence pour reconstituer des
capacités sanitaires pourquoi ce manque
d'anticipation alors que le gouvernement
avait bien été alertés sur ces carences
avant cette pandémie
peut-on parler d'un scandale d'état
c'est la question de ce soir et pour en
débattre nous sommes avec aurélie gros
conseillère régionale d'ile-de-france et
présidente de la france vraiment bon
soir aurélie gros ça vous florian
philippot conseiller régional du grand
est et président ait des patriotes
bonsoir florian philippot bonsoir
bonsoir à tous les deux donc et merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france il y a
dix ans la france avait un stock de près
de 2 milliards de masques des stocks qui
ont été progressivement détruits y
compris par le gouvernement actuel
c'est ce qu'a révélé une enquête du
monde cette semaine le ministre de la
santé à d'ailleurs été interpellé par le
député des alpes maritimes sur cette
question à l'assemblée écouter oui on a
détruit des masques monsieur sauty des
masques moisi inutilisable dont les
critères de filtration et de
respirabilité font que vous ne les
donnerai même pas votre lapin dans un
florian philippot le gouvernement
français a bien détruit des masques
c'est ce qu'on a appris cette semaine
via une enquête du journal le monde
alors que le gouvernement jusqu'à
présent rejeté la faute sur le
gouvernement précédent
c'est un mensonge dont il devra rendre
compte au gouvernement selon bon c'est
un mensonge supplémentaire c'est à dire
que on nous a quand même beaucoup menti
dans cette crise du côté du gouvernement
je ne rappelle que je vous rappelle que
le 13 mars encore le premier ministre
déclaré à la télévision que les masques
ne servait à rien et que la porte-parole
cib et mbia il disait qu'il ne fallait
pas emporté parce qu'on ne savait pas
emporter pour faire en réalité c'est une
scène ce fiasco total des masques qui
est très grave parce que le masque c'est
extrêmement efficace face à une épidémie
je crois que les pays d'europe centrale
sont en train de nous le démontrer le
maroc également qu'ils ont rendus depuis
début avril déjà le le port du masque
obligatoire à l'extérieur et c'est tout
ce fiasco c'est une coupe
duction puisqu'en réalité si on se
renseigne bien tout a changé à partir de
2011 2012 à la fin du mandat de nicolas
sarkozy
ça s'est accéléré notre désarmement
sanitaire s'est accélérée sous marisol
touraine et françois hollande
et puis ce fiasco sous emmanuel macron
et même des masques qu'on a continué de
brûler alors qu'on rare que l'épidémie
commencé dans notre pays c'est à dire
qu'à partir de 2011 bat on a fait passer
le budgétaire et le comptable avant le
sanitaire très clairement puisqu'on a
décidé que les stocks tactique comme on
dit de masques devait directement être
constitué par les hôpitaux par les
établissements sur le terrain et que
l'état lui se chargerait des stocks
stratégiques
il fit au fur et à mesure et bien on a
on a moins renouveler les stocks et on
n'a même pas vérifié que les hôpitaux
constitué bien leurs stops tactique
alors que l'on savait qu'ils étaient
étrangler financièrement
et puis ça nous a menés à cette
catastrophe et mais c'est ça n'est pas
rien cette affaire de masse parce que
derrière il ya probablement des
conséquences en terme de mortalité qui
sont dramatiques pour les gros
effectivement vous pensez que si la
france n'avait pas détruit ces masques
en tout cas sous ce gouvernement il y en
a eu et des masques de détruits
d'ailleurs olivier ferrand dit qu' il
était périmé or écouter écouter benoît
valais il était membre de la
coordination nationale du déconfinement
et à l'époque dgs de 2013 à 2018 et
ildiko non ces masques étaient
utilisables écoutez le ces derniers mois
certains masques pas encore détruit ou
un nouveau été expertisé les
informations que j'ai eu c'est que les
tests sont revenus de façon favorable
ça remet en question l'idée que le stock
de 616 millions étaient aussi dégradée
que ça pu être suggérées d'ailleurs je
n'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un dire de
manière formelle que ce stock était
inutilisable
de toute façon si ces masques devait
être remplacé alors si la doctrine reste
celle du milliard on devait à titre de
précaution reconstituer des stocks
stratégiques
voilà donc la doctrine française c'est
d'avoir un milliard de masques en stock
aurélie gros le gouvernement bon s'il
les a détruits passons mais il aurait dû
reconstituer les stocks que ont
nationalisé fait effectivement on peut
dire que le stock national le stock
stratégique
nationale n'a pas été remis au niveau où
il devait se trouver mais quand on
regarde ce qui a pu se passer
précédemment notamment avec madame
bachelot et ses nombreux masques qu'elle
avait qu'elle avait commandé au moment
du h1n1 et les nombreuses critiques dont
elle avait fait pas dit qu'on lui avait
fait sur le sujet je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas mettre un peu
plus mesuré dans ce que l'on dit si on
regarde ensuite qui aurait pu mieux
faire moins bien faire que l'actuel
gouvernement
si on regarde les ultralibéraux je crois
franchement qu'ils auraient supprimer
l'intégralité des stocks de masques ou
non d'un pragmatisme ou d'une idéologie
parce que la logique des plus tendues
veut qu'aujourd'hui en quelques heures
on peut avoir un nombre de masques
impressionnant qui arrivent sur le
territoire français il joue avec un on a
vu que c'était pas le chaos et les
grands pas il réussit à voir un nombre
de masques pour les soignants mais
au-delà de ça j'ose pas imaginer
l'article du monde relatant le nombre de
morts parce que des personnes auraient
utilisé des masques blancs filtrant les
démasque périmés certes il est facile
toujours d'aller critiqué le fait qu'on
détruit des masques mais à un moment je
crois qu'il faudrait être un peu plus
mesuré dans les propos on ne peut pas
toujours porté sur chaque fait que fait
le gouvernement chaque décision qu'il
prend notamment sur ses masques périmés
on peut pas les taxer de mauvaise foi
ils n'ont pas voulu détruire ces masques
pour les détruire
moi je pense aujourd'hui il faudrait
mieux primer sur l'union nationale et
est arrêté avec ce genre de polémiques
stériles et de polémiques qui ne jette
le flou sur ce gouvernement
effectivement mais aussi sur les
français entre eux je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
qui est extrêmement difficile
les citoyens ont envie de reprendre une
vie normale c'est compliqué
effectivement ils ont été plutôt flou
dans leur manière de gérer la crise avec
ses histoires de masques notamment
faut-il à emporter ou une faute il pas
emporté mais aujourd'hui levé la
personne n'avait prévu qu'à virus une
épidémie à quelques semaines près se
répandent sur les trois quarts du
territoire et est du territoire français
et mondial à moment donné ces stocks de
masques
c'est une question mais le fait que
cette épidémie s'est répandu sur la
terre entière à quelques semaines
d'intervalle vous imaginez bien que la
réaction quel que soit le gouvernement
est très compliqué à gérer
vous dites personne n'avait vu venir
cette crise pourtant il ya eu des
alertes à l'époque d'un certain jérôme
salle au moins on sait qui est
aujourd'hui le directeur de la direction
générale de la santé à l'époque
conseiller à la sécurité sanitaire de
marisol touraine
il avait lancé une alerte au
gouvernement écouter la possibilité de
survenue d'un événement naturels
d'ampleur avec un impact sur un grand
nombre de personnes des dommages
matériels importants
un impact financier et d'image et des
capacités de réaction des passes et doit
être sérieusement envisagée anticipées
la france n'est pas prête
notre pays doit adapter ses
organisations spécificités des crises
majeures à venir
donc c'était en 2000 16 ans et alertes
de jérôme salomon apparemment personne
n'a entendu non plus florian philippot
oui non peut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
de laquelle alala n'a pas été tirée en
réalité moi vous savez le gélules la
grande enquête du monde sur cette
affaire des masques je suis je ne
comptais pas en parler parce que je suis
impliqué mais puisque le monde m'a cité
je les dis en 2010 on n'avait jamais
participé à un rapport de l'inspection
générale de l'administration puisque
j'étais inspecteur d'administration
ministère de l'intérieur c'était le
rapport du sénateur giraud on lit ce
rapport aujourd'hui on l'avait écrit à
trois c'est exactement ce qui se passe
voilà on avait
lectrice ce qui risquait de se passer si
la france n'était pas prête face à une
épidémie nationale où une crise
d'ampleur nationale et je constate que
dix ans plus tard ce rapport n'a pas été
suivi d'effet il y en avait eu d'autres
il y avait eu le rapport sauzée en 2005
de l'excellent inspecteur général sauzée
à l'inspection générale d'administration
aussi donc non on ne peut pas dire qu'on
a qu'il n'y a pas eu d' alerte c'est
faux moi je pense que les gens on ne
peut pas les déresponsabiliser il devra
y avoir et pas simplement des
commissions d enquête parlementaire
parce que je fais un boîtier confiance à
ce genre de choses
faudra des procès parce que n'importe
qui en france quand il fait quelque
chose de mal
eh ben il ya un procès il s'appelle la
justice donc il y aura une défense sur à
une accusation mais c'est à moi de faire
ce défoliant philippe hausse et on peut
comparer cette affaire au sang contaminé
ou pas mais oui mais oui bien sûr qu'on
peut qu'on peut comparer parce que on
sait que le masque c'est efficace s'il
ya une grande étude là qui a été fait
par eux l'université de cambridge avec
d'ailleurs participation de l'école de
économique de guerre de paris et de
haies et hong kong qui a montré que si
une population porte à 80 % un masque
alors il ya trois fois moins de
mortalités que le confinement sans
masque
et si même la population le porte à 90%
alors le virus peut disparaître en 50
jours vous savez en corée du sud ils ont
fait ça a très tôt l' en république
tchèque ils ont fermé les frontières et
ils ont imposé le port du masque début
avril
et ben résultat aujourd'hui s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux que nous donc on peut pas
dire personne ne savait c'est la
fatalité ça nous est tombé dessus ça
n'est pas vrai on a désarmé l'état quand
l' usine de plaintel qui fabrique et 200
millions de masques en france donc en
bretagne a été délocalisée en tunisie et
à fermer
l'état n'a pas bougé le petit doigt
voilà donc moi je suis désolé il ya des
gens qui sont responsables
il ya des gens qui devront répondre de
ses responsabilités sinon c'est trop
facile
ou lé gros le 4 avril olivier ferrand
avait annoncé la commande de 2 milliards
de masques à la chine qui ne sont
toujours pas là on le voit bien
néanmoins vendredi c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a fait un point presse
sur ces masques il a annoncé 900
millions d'usagers pas de masque 1 900
millions d' usage par semaine pour les
français ils comptent évidemment la
durée de vie des masques dits grand
public aujourd'hui on est prêt demain on
est prêt pour que la france soit équipée
en masques leur masque grand public je
pense que les collectivités
territoriales ont pris les
pas puisqu'un grand nombre de
collectivités territoriales que ce soit
les municipalités les départements les
agglomérations et les régions ont
commandé un grand nombre de stocks de
masques grand public pour pouvoir
équiper des populations donc dire qu'on
est près j'espère qu'on sera peut-être
pas la première semaine puisque on sait
que la pression sur la fabrication de
ces masques qui se font d'ailleurs en
français et là dessus je dirais que j'ai
eu une convergence avec monsieur
philippe où je pense qu'à un moment
donné il va falloir aussi re
nationaliser certaines de nos
productions et certaines de nos
entreprises et que ça c'est une des
leçons on peut tirer de cette crise etc
masque en tissu alternative en sont la
preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
que les collectivités ont
essentiellement commandé en france et je
trouve que c'est très bien donc ça va
nous permettre effectivement d'équipé à
certain nombre de temps en tout cas
gratuitement les citoyens dans ses
premières semaines de sorties sortir de
déconfinement et pour le coup je pense
qu'on sera prêt mais c'est plus les
collectivités qui ont joué le jeu pour
le coup et c'est cette formidable
solidarité entre l'état et les
collectivités qui ont joué le jeu à la
demande de l'état aussi il faut le
reconnaître et je crois que ça c'est un
exemple qu'on doit tous revenir de cette
crise
alors vous parlez des collectivités qui
met effectivement à disposition des
personnes les masques gratuitement or
les masques sont en vente aujourd'hui
dans les grandes surfaces dans les
pharmacies ou dans les bureaux de tabac
florian philippot et c'est un budget
assez conséquent pour les français oui
c'est on ne peut pas demander en même
temps aux gens de par exemple dans les
transports publics porter
obligatoirement le masque et leur
demander de débourser plusieurs dizaines
d'euros par personne pour une famille ça
peut devenir considérable quand le
revenu est modeste
chaque mois donc si vous voulez il faut
là il faut être conséquent si c'est
obligatoire dans certains lieux il faut
offrir ces masques je prends encore
l'exemple de la corée du sud parce que
sauf que j ai des amis qui habitent
explique depuis des mois et des mois
dans les syndics d'immeubles ont leur
dépose des paquets de masques pour la
famille chaque semaine voilà donc c'est
s'est pris en charge par la collectivité
et je pense que ça doit l'être
surtout quand on rend le masque
obligatoire dans certains certains
certains domaines notamment dans l'est
dans les transports
public mais mais là si vous voulez on
est enfin je pense que notre pays a
montré qu'il était extrêmement affaibli
et appauvrit on dit il faut entreprises
notre pays un christophe castaner va se
dit impressionnée d'ailleurs par la
capacité à réagir d or du strip
françaises qui se sont reconvertis dans
la fabrication de masques oui et encore
et encore on n'a pas beaucoup mobilisé
vous savez en france on est montés je
crois à 7 millions de masques produit en
france par semaine pour une grande
puissance industrielle que nous sommes
ce n'est pas grand chose le maroc qui
n'a que 35 millions d'habitants je crois
qu'il est 23 fois plus pauvre que la
france ait produit 7 millions de masques
par jour
donc si vous voulez on n'a pas eu cet
état stratège qui a réquisitionné qui a
mis en place une filière d'économie de
guerre puisque le président direct 8
vous avez parlé d'une guerre au début
contre l'épidémie
et c'est vrai que l'état est devenu très
faible parce que depuis des décennies se
soumet à l'europe il se soumet aux
marchés tout est délocalisée il n'a pas
le droit de faire de patriotisme
économique qui n'a pas droit de
nationaliser des filières en vain
résultat c'est qu'aujourd'hui on le paye
très cher
je rappelle d'ailleurs que pendant cette
pandémie en plein moment où on disait
qu'il fallait relooke alizés la
production nationale
l'europe continue et de signer des
accords de libre échange pour tout
délocaliser comme elle l'a fait au
mexique avec le mexique fin avril et
avec le vietnam fin mars
alors ça si c'est que ça n'est pas un
nouveau scandale faut m'expliquer ce que
c'est alors à partir de mercredi
effectivement vous l'avez dit florian
philippot le port du masque sera
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun sous peine d'amendé
je vais vous montrer une photo de
christophe castaner cette semaine
christophe castaner qui a posé le 6 mai
dans une usine de masques dan lin un
ministre qui ne porte pas de masque au
milieu d'un groupe de plumes des
personnes ça vous inspire quoi aurélie
gros jeu ça m'inspire que c'est pas
raisonnable et ce n'est pas montré
l'exemple que de faire ça moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les responsables
politiques quel qu'il soit qu'il soit
ministre ou simple élus doivent montrer
l'exemple et porter un masque pour se
protéger eux mêmes mais surtout pour
protéger les autres parce qu'on le sait
que ce soit un masque chirurgical ou à
masquer grand public
ça permet essentiellement de protéger
celui qui est en face donc un ministre
qui ne portent pas de
je trouve que c'est relativement et est
responsable mais je le dirai d'une d'un
citoyen lambda même s'il n'était pas
ministre donc voilà ce que vous dites il
est censé montrer l'exemple a quand même
on est bien d'accord donc là dessus je
ne cautionne pas ce genre d'image alors
il s'est excusé un christophe castaner
néanmoins florian philippot ça montre
quand même encore un couac 1 après
effectivement toutes ces déclarations
que l'on a entendu sur la difficulté
pour mettre un masque que les français
ne savaient pas le maître etc
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est ce
gouvernement c'est une symphonie de
couacs et de fausses notes depuis depuis
des mois maintenant ça commence à
devenir vraiment gênant enfin entre les
bourdes les gaffes de la porte parole si
bête ndiaye depuis des mois à chaque
fois qu'elle qu'elle apparaît à la
télévision c'est pour faire une gaffe
encore aujourd'hui je crois avec une
polémique sur la cigarette dans son
bureau de ministre
c'est quand même pas rassurant imaginer
les français quand même derrière il ya
des gens qui l' ont perdu des proches et
des gens qui sont morts dans cette
affaire il ya des gens qui se sont
retrouvés seuls à l'hôpital qui ont
perdu des parents qui sont morts seuls
dans les maisons de retraite dans des
conditions d'ailleurs un ding donc on
n'a pas le droit quand on est le
gouvernement français qui en plus est un
pays qui a du ressort qu'à des moyens on
n'est pas le pays plus pauvre du monde
loin de là on n'a pas le droit de se
comporter comme ça on n'a pas le droit
de faire un peu n'importe quoi d'être
amateur de donner des ordres et
contre-ordres quitte ensuite d'ailleurs
à s'excuser comme vous venez de le dire
concernant le ministre de l'intérieur
sur sur cette affaire s'excuser non je
veux dire on doit être exemplaire
alors on a droit parfois une erreur tout
être humain le droit à l'erreur mais on
ne le savait on ne doit pas persévérer
dans l'erreur et on n'a pas droit à la
faute en revanche surtout quand il
s'agit de la santé des gens moi j'espère
on parle souvent du monde d'après de la
france d'après honnêtement je pense
qu'elle ne pourra pas se faire avec eux
avec cette équipe quand même d'amateurs
et je n'oserais à se refonder sur des
nouveaux principes qui seront ceux de la
compétence et la capacité notre pays à
se réarmer
face aux crises alors la condition
évidemment est ciné qua none pour ce
déconfinement c'est la capacité on teste
olivier ferrand a dit que la france
étaient capables de tester massivement
lors de son point presse cette semaine
écoutez le ces dernières semaines tout a
été fait pour être en capacité de
dépister les personnes vulnérables
mais aussi l'ensemble des personnes
symptomatique et les cas contactez la
france est prête pour tester massivement
la capacité de dépistage et dès
aujourd'hui au niveau des besoins
estimés
qu'en pensez-vous aurélie gros est ce
que au niveau de la collectivité c'est
clair est-ce que les gens savent comment
ça va se passer c'est ces dépistages
quelle quelle procédure faut-il suivre
notamment d'abord allé chez son médecin
bien sûr bien sûr je crois que les en
fait on repasse au stade qui s'était
passé avant même qu'on soit en
confinement après nous n'avions pas il y
avait en france n'est pas les capacités
pour tester massivement et je pense que
chacun réagissez à tâtons aujourd'hui je
crois que la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est quand même la performance et
la réactivité de notre système de santé
et son mode de financement et la
capacité à faire des tests en fait
partie d'ailleurs mais on peut le
président chinois du retard à l'allumage
en les labos a priori dans cette affaire
c'est bien pour ça que je parle de ce
système de santé dans le global et on
peut dire franchement peut mieux faire
on le dit je l'assumé peut mieux faire
mais franchement face à cette gravité de
la crise je crois que franchement le
plus le plus important c'est quand même
de tirer notre chapeau
aujourd'hui à tous et soignants et au
contraire peut-être pointé du doigt
alors moi je pointerais pas du doigt
forcément le gouvernement mais une
administration qui est trop vertical et
qui est trop éloigné du terrain à
l'image de la chambre de santé grand
test qui voulait fermer des lits de
réanimation en plein milieu de
l'épidémie ce qui était quand même
aveyron est ce que je remarque en
entendant monsieur philippe hausse qui
confirme en tout cas ce que je voulais
dire ce soir c'est que le coronavirus il
a mis en lumière d'autres choses
notamment un nouveau virus qui est
vraiment lui pour le coup mortifère pour
pour les populations et pour les
citoyens c'est le développement
quotidien du complotisme je suis désolé
de le dire sur les réseaux sociaux
toutes ces thèses qui circulent sur les
tests sur les masses et ceux qui tentent
balle heureusement de mettre un peu de
rationalité
dedans sont rapidement toujours accusé
de ne pas servir les intérêts de notre
peuple
et heureusement nous avons une chance de
trouver un accent tout ça qui est
positif forcément et c'est cet immense
élan de solidarité que l'épidémie a
déclenché avec les citoyens les
associations et cette logique de
proximité de nos collectivités avec une
réelle entraide les a je pense que c'est
exceptionnel
aujourd'hui peut mieux faire dans ce
système de santé sur les tests sur les
masques évidemment sur les capacités
d'accueil des lits on a prouvé qu'on
pouvait mieux faire et comment comparer
par les articles du monde
l'article du monde forcément sera
toujours à charge donc l'article du
monde dit il ça a été bien géré et
pourquoi ça aurait été à charge florian
philippot très court il nous reste dix
secondes et pratiquement peut-être son
par habitant 77 fois plus de morts que
maroc on a infiniment plus de morts par
habitant que les 90% des pays du monde
et voilà donc dire quand on critique
quand on met au pointe du doigt cela
parce que derrière il ya des familles
endeuillées encore c'est du complotisme
moi ya pas de complotiste dans ce que je
dis je lis des choses factuelles et je
dis que notre pays a mal agi dans cette
affaire
les soignants eux ont été formidables et
héroïque mais le gouvernement a failli
tout rejeter sur l'administration c'est
un petit peu facile quand la rs annonce
une décision c'est qu'elle a été validée
par le ministre par définition
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce débat
merci aurélie go et merci florian
philippot est d'avoir participé à ce
face à face politique